só tem 21 hoje vou ensinar como fazer
uma em quatro semi automática para vocês
poderem fazer este projecto usar
basicamente de folhas a4 de impressora
cidade um pedaço do pão é que os dados e
fazer as caixas de cereais final nossas
caixas dublagem é bastante simples de
encontrar aqui é o bem fininho cidade de
três de lástima que o escritório mas não
é que o mais fraquinho aquele elemento
mais grosso que é mais forte e fita e
que ainda falta mais um que cola cola
quente você pode usar as escolas mas a
cola quente fica muito mais resistente a
cápsula então eu consegue agora nos
testes depois ao tutorial passo a passo
então bora lá pessoal
primeiro vão ter que ir lá uma folha com
os fosse uma rifa
caso vocês não consigam fazer ela bem
fininha e vou deixar um link de
inscrição você quer regular e eu vou
ensinar mais devagar ok
depois de fazerem a fifa tem que rolar
uma folha a volta do modo a fazer um
clube no final prendam com fita por não
ser largar tudo fica assim mas bordas
para fora então leva um pedaço maior e
sellen tudo dobra em moda fazer um
triângulo isósceles seja quando os lados
iguais traça a linha e depois corda está
para fazer uma rifa ligeiramente mais
pequena
depois corta em segmentos de cinco
centímetros
eu cortei site pedaços mas vocês podem
pôr mais ou menos isso vai depender da
vossa mão por ter outro pedaço dois
centímetros e agora vou começar a rolar
vejam que o primeiro segmento e acaba
onde acabam última ea partir daí vai
tudo ligeiramente para trás ok pois
encaixa em uma rifa na outra ou seja a
pequenina em caixa é grande prenda com
fita e de uma forma parecida com uma
coronha eu gosto de fazer que é o
detalhe traz é mais clara opcional
sempre nesta partida podem usar só fita
se quiserem
afinal é só encaixar as duas partes
agora vamos fazer o gatilho para depois
disso é se vocês quiserem que a tinta
pois vai ser um pouco complicado então
convém fazer logo aqui em simples
basicamente o hull com uma parte maior
que a outra simples mas bastante eficaz
vejam que o design no população se vocês
quiserem eu deixei 10 querem ver melhor
o deixei uma fotografia no facebook
então vou lá e venha com mais cuidado
então podem por falsa mas basicamente é
fazer uma caixa de fósforos
é só escolher se você estiver em uma
caixa de fósforo destas bem fininhas ela
também dá pra fazer com isso
hoje é só adaptar o tamanho da caixa
vejam aqui no final em que aprender para
ficar mesmo com uma caixa
agora eu vou incorporar a caixa no
domingo saiu perdedor no caso aqui ver o
comprimento da caixa que cinco cêntimos
com valores porém mesmo pela caixa não
vou medir 5 depois de kharja pode não
encaixar muito banho fica folgado
depois de verem é só fazer esta abertura
de usarem um x a peça aquelas dos
médicos é que facilita bastante a vida
mas vocês conseguem fazer com outro
importante acompanhar lâmina bem afiada
e se vocês forem crianças peçam ajuda
modo toque nesta quarta é muito
importante você encaixar e rifa dentro
do tubinho e depois é que vão colar
caixa de fotos
vamos dizer assim por que vocês não
encaixarem a fifa quando forem colar
essa parte é provável que entra dentro
do cano e vai ele vai impedir que as
barras saindo por choque
vejam que eu olhei para trás a para
tucano
agora vou começar a andar no força
armada aí porque desta forma é muito
frágil
vou começar por fazer um guarda mão com
tenho certeza alguém disse
agora depois vocês têm que tomar uma
rifa cortam a parte mais frágil depois
tem que contornar a volta é bastante
simples eu fiz o mesmo em outras árvores
mas está uma folha uma força é está a
arma porque vocês forem ver a agora ela
fica muito fácil mas depois de pularem
isso fica muito forte mesmo
pronto agora é só colar do cine pe assim
como ele é conselheiro da escola porque
se você usar outra escola tem que
esperar bastante mesmo item por muita
cola e identificarmos a esta causa é
barata
claro que eu também nem toda a gente
pode usar por causa de dadá vocês
poderem ajudar alguém a certeza que não
vão importar nos ajudaram
gostava de ter posto um lança-granadas
ainda pensava em lançar granadas que as
pessoas fizeram as armas pois podem
encaixar lança granadas na frente acho
que é uma mentira eu sei como faz tudo
pronto e tenho vários projetos alimenta
tanto pois vão encaixar esta parte por
cima tem 23 centímetros está no modo que
nesta parte da frente fique nove
centímetros e jean ramos acaba aquela
parte grande combina com aquelas meninas
foi a volta e agora nos açores ou
enfeitar a ficar parecido com a arma que
é bastante simples só rifas moldadas com
o formato
pois o trabalho acima em triângulo tem
uma parte em 90° vejam que fica de
projetos como o cano
é só vocês olharem para uma imagem e
pronto e que o caminho da frente é o uma
rifa de um veículo em uma folha de papel
enrolado à volta do canal num campo de
início de maio
achei que ficou sem uma gringa que vá
para ter dono então eu tentei mas é mais
do vigia ficou melhor e o design ficou
mais bonita
a arma já estava praticamente feita
agora falta fazer uma coisa que empurra
as bolas para dentro aí não é só fazer o
que faz com que minas tem que vender com
fita em várias partes quer dizer que em
três partes vejam aqui é importante é
ter a largura 3,7 e 3,8 e uma coisa que
talvez vocês não têm hora para nós e
caixa de fósforos tem para pintada para
dentro e esta parte a entrar as bolas
têm para pintada por fora isso porque
porque os contactar as duas partes
pintadas a fricção é muito nova a cair
agora esperar o contrário flexão muito
grande é isso vai dar problema depois as
balas podar não tenho certeza mas fica
melhor
ou seja o trânsito vai ser menor depois
é só colar desta maneira certa atenção
para fazer um volume maior que caixa é
que eu tenho que andar livremente
agora é só coar o outro lago
enquanto vocês viram encaixa muito bem
agora vou fazer o pincel muita atenção
vejam o tamanho fica a mãe do carregador
vazio onde eu marquei e depois mais um
pedacinho para depois voltarem para a
taxa
logo para trás e vão usar dois elásticos
se lá se vão querer mais forte que o
normal
ok então se vocês tiverem carlos lage os
mais fraquinhos podem tentar usando três
ok vão dando várias voltas com fita e
depois com uma cola no super cola compor
nas partes que vão estar agora é muito
importante talvez porém escola porque
não quiserem não vai funcionar quer
dizer vai funcionar de modo muito
difícil ou não funcionar porque acontece
quando os expoentes de cola fita de
plástico e o plástico em contato com o
plástico faz pouco atrito você já vai
escorregar facilmente e plantar uma já
está feita agora só falta mesmo fazer e
as balas e não quer só marcar um lado
melhor que o outro
no final é só aprender com fita mas
corta em gerenciamento do do comprimento
da onu em cavar pronto agora é só
encaixar as partes todas encaixar o
pistão e elásticos e vou passar pela
aquela parte da lei de mira
por isso é muito importante vocês porém
bastante colar é para que aguente as
balas seis balas mas vocês podem pôr
mais ou menos
é só fazer um carregador maior ou menor
não queira investir lá cinco para
ajudarem pra lá pra dentro é só cortar o
elástico fazer um nó e já está foi agora
o funcionamento puxam para trás até que
é o das mechas para dentro
é é que a bola já entrou dentro do carro
que vocês quiserem disparar tem que
puxar para trás depois é só carregar no
que tinha só um fio
o estado e tenho conseguido fazer você
acreditar que ela só deixar um like e se
inscreva para acompanhar os próximos por
jet e se você quiser alguma coisa
especial é só deixar os comentários dos
comentários que ouvir mais
eu tenho sempre fazer trazer para o
canal é é extinta bar legal